so let's rock five standard invite here
we go okay so this is what you call in
eternity five minutes compared to bullet
let's try this let's try this and then
this and then that so this has
transferred transition to an ID or f--
night or f-- and let's try an
accelerated type of expansion here again
well if you've been here from the
beginning you'll note that I had already
emphasized how important it is to to do
what what are emphasized oh as white be
very cautious of this C 4 square so it's
a big decision on my part as to whether
or not I want to go one or two squares
might my opponent be trying to be
playing this maybe let's do this and I
need to take good good care of the d5
square good good care of the d5 square
why is that the case because it's a hole
because it's a hole and I don't want my
opponent to be able to be pivoting about
on that square with their pieces I also
don't want them to be able to let's say
throw all their heavy pieces on this
file and that's um what they're getting
prepared to do now time to come up with
a game plan time to come up with a game
plan right here this is what I need to
be concerned about there is um something
to be said about this g4 move and how if
the g4 g5 gets in too quickly
my night might end up having to go to
age five or here if it ends up coming
here like 97g four if I really want to
end up keeping this night around on the
queenside I'll have to play Knight b6
and then 97 kind of like falling in one
another's footsteps the other idea is
this and that is to put a halt to that
idea so next up I'm looking for in 97
and I guess I could be doing this Bishop
move but I think it's better to just get
this Knight out and about or maybe not
maybe not actually there might be
something to I'm keeping that night
around on this square and I don't know
that that's the way to go I really I
just don't know let's do let's do that
and I'm assuming they're gonna go Queen
side right so this is I'm just kind of
just not sure and even though I could
Castle in this position I'm hesitant to
do that because I think my King would be
much less safe castled opposed to
actually sitting on its home square he
ate so no rook c8 and maybe um okay rook
c8 seems very purposeful right now
what about Knight here no no no rook
here is right I'm pretty sure okay and
that's a very purposeful just get that
King off the same file now I think this
is good might be six here we go Knight
right here this Knight is sort of out of
play although I could see some instances
of the night maybe coming here being
that the queen is watching over it maybe
like um well actually Knight here is no
good that's actually dropping upon now
but earlier I would think there was
stuff with like Knight here and after I
take take bishop here there's something
like Knight a5 - c6
so if there is this pawn that kind of
ends up in this pocket right here ends
up in this hole then I think you know I
I won't have to worry of let's say the
pressure that they could be mounting on
this D file but that would be at pawn on
d5 is providing a support point on c6
that the knight may very well be able to
access quickly by way of a v c6 so no
wow okay they are just saying you know
I'm coming after you I am coming after
you whether you like it or not I'm
coming after you and they're also
diverting my attention away from this
square if I have to capture in either
direction with these pieces than the
knight maybe come in here Bishop takes
Queen takes Knight here with tempo type
of stuff can be happening so I wonder if
inserting first b4 is a good idea I
think that that is a good idea I'm gonna
run with that so it's getting very
dynamic and I think I net upon with this
a variation I could chop here with the
bishop and then chop here and then chop
here and then maybe come here let's
figure this out two minutes two-minute
warning Knight takes pawn takes Knight
takes Bishop takes is on my rook Wow can
I keep it simpler there also on this
pawn
oh man man I don't know what to do
Knight takes pawn takes Knight takes why
can't it be easier let's try that let's
try that and then well let's give it a
shot oh this is gonna be weird do I have
this move no what's not working
something with like Queen takes Knight
takes here for work oh okay I got to
recapture like this and now they're on
my um they're on my rook they're on my
rook and my king okay now they give me
what let's do this I think taking that
pawn would have been strong they're
gonna allow my knight to stick around
okay they gave up the light square
bishop I don't want a castle I think
King here their knight is out of play
thankfully their knight is out of play
and I think I just want to scoop my King
over there's no need to Castle now my
rook could become active just by way of
taking here a couple times
so I'm on this I'm on this twice I'm on
that four times actually and I just want
to trade some so I'm looking to for this
move looking for that move and now I
just want to defend how do I defend
probably this cuz then I could play here
maybe maybe I want to push in the center
as well less than 45 seconds planning
planning while this move this move and
then d4 this night is out of play I
think I like my rooks better than their
rooks so let's go with this okay now
let's actually kick this night away and
actually they were on the pun I could
have also considered a central expansion
if Knight here okay the night let's
expand the night is definitely in a
tough spot okay so let's get my bishop
here I have good coordination and let's
get this here Queen takes rook in some
variations let's play here um I miss
pond oh there are my queen oh I'm not
just time go quicker go quicker I just
want to play this move open up that dart
diagonal and then get on it there we go
and then get okay oh no no no no no okay
let's do this
is this working out somehow oh they're
gonna give check I have that block
though right Bishop back I just want to
get my bishop out of there eight how
much time do I have left I want my
bishop out of there bishop here six
seconds they're getting mated oh man
I can't talk how to pre move like a
maniac oh oh oh it's uh what a game good
game
Oh down to the wire I probably should
probably lucky to even get away with the
draw right there oh man good game oh
let's go back that guy nuts that
definitely got nuts right there I
probably even got lucky to get a draw
okay this is a night orff I already
spoke quite a bit and I think yeah I
think thoroughly enough about what um
white might try to do with g4 here I'm
not sure about the H pawn move I'm not
sure about that I don't know what it
what it really does again as black be
cautious about castling your king is
probably a bit better off staying right
where it is so this is these are these
are good I mean this is a good idea you
know get off of that same file g4 and
then wow did it get messy got really
messy and I burned a ton of time at this
point takes takes I don't know I thought
I thought actually Bishop takes pawn
okay yeah still take the knight how
about just take the pawn right now this
is what I was thinking like Bishop takes
after I recommend after I rip my move
after I move my rook Bishop to b5 giving
check enough just coming here but you
don't have to take on this square you
see it's um when you take on h5 I can be
assured maybe are a bit more assured
that my rook could have some play or
come into the game by way of the age
file however if you keep the tension
between
ponds and run with Bishop takes a six my
rook moves Bishop check my king moves
most likely I don't want to kind of just
retreat and work myself into a pin so
Bishop takes rook moves bishop check
King here now how about a move such as
g5 and then it's like well what do I do
with my rook uh it seems like I'd be
having to play g6 and then King g7 but
maybe in the meantime there's f4 and
this diagonal opens up and my King can't
get safe in other words so in summary I
think maybe maintaining this tension is
going to benefit you by keeping me
guessing about you either taking or
pushing forward is going to be is gonna
be difficult for me to be meeting